JONATHAN BERI: So this session,
we're going to
introduce you all to the
Google+ Sign-In and the
Google+ platform.
You may have seen the Google+
Sign-In for the very first
time this morning, during
the keynote.
Or you browsed the Docs and
want to get started.
So this session is for you.
We're going to go over the core
features of the Google+
platform and the Google+ Sign-In
button and show you
just enough code to give you
the right set of context.
Before we get too far into it,
allow me to introduce myself.
My name is Jonathan Beri.
I'm a developer advocate on
the Google+ platform.
If you have questions about
this session afterwards or
want to learn more about the
Google+ platform and just
generally talk to somebody on
the Google+ team, add me to
your Circles.
That's a link to my profile.
That's the best way to
get a hold of me.
And yeah, I'm responsive.
And you can ask me technical
questions or anything else.
I'm also joined by my colleague
from Google+.
RIDHIMA KEDIA: Hi, I'm Ridhima
Kedia, a technical leader in
Google+ platform.
JONATHAN BERI: Awesome,
thank you, Ridhima.
So today's agenda--
we're going to cover four main
areas of the Google+ platform.
The first and most important is
the Google+ Sign-In button.
This is a widget, a plug-in, a
snippet of code that you can
add to your applications to
enable users to connect their
Google accounts to
your services.
And with it, we add a little bit
of Google magic that we're
going to show you a
little bit later.
Once the user is signed in,
they've granted access to
their Google profile.
So you can start integrating
that profile, making a
personalized and engaging
experience
and a returning user.
With Google+ Sign-In, we also
introduced a new form of
sharing, a type of targeted
sharing that enables users to
reach out to their friends on
Google and then bring them
back to your app in
an engaged way.
So they can start using your
application in a social way,
instantaneously.
And the last piece we're going
to cover is what we call App
Activities.
This is a way to enable you to
write activities to Google
that users are doing
within your app.
And then Google will surface
those activities in meaningful
times across Google, at
the right moment,
for the right user.
Great.
So let's start thinking
social.
I work with a lot of developers,
and they tell me
the same thing.
I want to use social
platforms.
I want to integrate social into
my applications, but I
don't know where to begin.
Let's pause for a minute and
think about what does it mean
to be social in our
daily lives?
It's really about two things--
people and connections.
So similarly, to enable social
within your applications, it's
about bringing people and
connections into your apps.
And the reason why you want to
do that as a developer is to
acquire new users and
increase engagement.
And in fact, with the Google+
platform and Google+ Sign-In,
the features we built were
targeted to make sure that we
can help you get new users
and increase engagement.
And throughout this talk, we'll
mention those features,
where they help you get users
and increase engagement.
And a bit of a spoiler--
it's all the features.
All right?
Great.
So let's talk about the
Google+ Sign-In.
And where it starts, it
starts with a button.
The Google+ Sign-In is a button
you can add to your web
apps, to your mobile
apps, and your iOS.
It's a plug-in, it's a widget,
it's a piece of HTML that
enables users to connect
their Google
account with your service.
It's a seamless experience to
allow them to authorize you to
start accessing their
profile information.
And when you add the Google+
Sign-In button to your apps,
you can be confident that users
are going to start to
use it as a way to log in.
That's because Google
is a trusted brand--
a brand built on privacy
and security.
We have things like two-factor
authentication, multi-login,
and the controlled sharing of
Circles that gets carried over
with the Google+ Sign-In
product.
And as developer, Google handles
the authorization for
you, which is a very complicated
problem that we
help you solve.
So a user clicks that button,
and we take them through the
authorization flow.
Here's the authorization screen
that a user might see
if they're using Jolicloud.
And there's three
major sections.
There's the branding at the top,
the set of permissions
you're asking the users to
confirm, and the ability for
them to accept or deny
your request.
Let's walk through each part.
So the top is the branding.
This is controlled by you, as
a developer, to let the user
know who they are about
to sign into.
Now let's walk through
those permissions.
The very first line is the basic
Google+ API permissions.
This enables you, as a
developer, to access the
user's public profile
information--
things like their first and
last name, their profile
picture, their Google ID, and
anything else they might have
enabled on their profile
to be public.
But it also includes the people
that they follow in
their Circles.
This is a flat list of the
people and the pages that
they've added on Google+.
And you'll notice there is
an Edit List option.
This is the very first place
that we provide control and
trust to the user, so they can
say who you, as a developer,
know about in their Circles.
This creates confidence
for the Google+
Sign-In as a login solution.
The next line is another
permission.
This is actually the Google
Drive permission.
So with Google+ Sign-In, we
enable you to use multiple
Google APIs in a single
authorization flow.
This is very powerful, because
Google provides a lot of great
services that could benefit
you as a developer.
And the user only has to
authorize those services in a
single dialogue.
The next line is their
Google email.
This is their official email
they use to log in every
single day.
There's not a form field they
might mistype that email or a
spam account they might want
to not deal with, if they
register for your service.
So you can trust that this is
their real Google email.
So if you have existing user
accounts, and you see this
email, this is most
likely that user.
And if you get emails from other
networks, you can use
that as a join to combine
user accounts.
And the last bit is the
permission to write App
Activities on behalf
of that user.
And like the List field, the
user can control just exactly
who can see their activities and
which activities are being
written on their behalf.
So now for that magic--
a little bit of the
Google magic.
When a user signs in the Google+
Sign-In button, and
you have an App in the Google
Play Store, if that user has
an Android device, when they
click that button, in that
flow, we will ask them, would
you like to install this
Android app, as well?
And Google handles
that for you.
So we're pushing your Android
app directly to engaged users,
who already have connected with
your service, directly to
the phone in their pocket.
They don't even have
to take it out.
This is the number one easiest
way for Android developers to
acquire Android users.
And this is one of
those features
that seeing is believing.
So let's watch a short
clip from one of
our integration partners.
PETE MOLETIERRE: The main driver
behind our success is
having a product that's
easy to use and
delights our customers.
Over-the-air install provides
users with a seamless
experience.
They create their account or
log into it for the first
time, and our Android
application is automatically
installed on the user's
smartphone, so that they can
have a delightful first
time experience.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JONATHAN BERI: Awesome, huh?
And as we saw in the keynote
today, if they've logged in
already on the web, they have
that Android app on their
phone, they're seamlessly signed
in with seamless sign
on across platforms.
Now we've been out for about
two months now, and we're
seeing fantastic conversion
rates for users.
So we announced just yesterday
that 40% of users who see this
dialogue say yes.
And that doesn't include the
users who already have your
Android app installed.
So this is a number one way
to get new Android users.
So now, I'm going to turn it
over to Ridhima to show us
some that code to add the
Google+ Sign-In button to your
applications.
RIDHIMA KEDIA: Thank
you, Jonathan.
When we designed Google+
Sign-In, one of our key goals
was to reduce integration
complexity for developers.
It really is amazingly simple
to integrate this into your
application.
For example, we use OAuth
2.0 to allow the user to
authorize your app.
But all the implementation
details are completely hidden
away from you.
You don't have to worry about
any implementation details
regarding OAuth 2.0.
This integration simplicity has
been extended across all
the different platforms that
we support, be it web,
Android, or iOS.
If you remember nothing else
from this talk, please
remember our developer site,
developers.google.com/+.
We have quick start, sample
code, reference material to
guide you through your
development.
Let's quickly talk through all
the integration steps.
The very first step is to go
to the API console and
register your application.
On doing that, you will
receive a client ID.
Please make note of
this client ID.
We will use it in the sign up
process to identify your
application.
Now let's take the
web JavaScript
library for an example.
What does it take to put that
button on your web page?
You need to load a single
JavaScript library from
Google, and you need to add
markup on your page where you
want us to render the button--
that's it.
We take it from there.
We will parse your page and
render the button, based on
the configuration options
that you specify.
The button will be rendered,
localized in the language of
the currently logged
in Google user.
And we also allow you to use
custom styling to tweak the
look of the button.
All we ask is that you respect
our branding guidelines.
These are posted on the
developer site that I
mentioned earlier.
Let's talk through
the different
options that are available.
By specifying the g-signin
class, you tell us where in
your DOM you want us to
render the button.
Remember the client ID we just
fetched from the API console.
You need to specify that here,
so that we can identify your
application.
So when you walk through the
content dialogue, we saw that
your app can ask the user
for certain permissions.
Plus.login is the very basic
scope for Google+ platform
integration, which allows you
to fetch the user's profile
data, meaning their
name, profile
URL, age range, gender.
It also allows you to
fetch the people
in the user's Circles.
In addition, it allows you
to write back different
activities that the user is
taking within your app back to
Google, so that we can surface
it in interesting
and relevant contexts.
Your app may require additional
permissions.
So for example, if you need to
access the user's files, you
would ask for the Drive
scope here.
Suppose you use Wallet as part
of your payment solution.
You would also ask for the
payments.makepayment scope here.
By specifying a cookie policy,
you allow us to optimize
performance by caching OAuth 2.0
tokens by storing cookies
on your site.
The complete documentation for
this is available on our
developer site.
Remember these App Activities we
keep talking about that you
can write back to Google?
Using request visible actions,
you specify what are the
different activity types that
you would like to write back.
There are over 10 different
activity types to choose from,
and you can specify more than
one activity type here.
For example, if you wanted to
write back user purchase
events, you would specify
the buy activity here.
You can specify a JavaScript
callback that will be called
on a successful auth result.
This could be as a result of
the user clicking Accept on
the consent dialogue or as the
result of auto-approval, in
case the user has ever
authorized your app before on
Android or web.
In any case, in this callback,
we recommend that you hide the
Sign-In button, and you can go
ahead and personalize your app
to give the user a better
experience.
So here is the code snippet that
you would need to add to
your page to load the JavaScript
library we talked
about earlier.
This is the same plusone.js that
we use for all Google+
plug-ins, including
the +1 button.
So if you have integrated +1
already on your site, you
would already have this code
snippet, and you don't need to
add it again.
plusone.js parses the page and
renders the button, based on
your configuration options.
As Jonathan just showed you,
one of the most amazing
features of Google+ Sign-In is
driving over-the-air installs
of your Android app right
from the Sign-In flow.
It's completely trivial
for you to set up.
All you do is specify the app
package name, and we will take
it from there.
We will decide how and when to
show the dialogue and all the
different error conditions.
As I mentioned earlier, this
integration simplicity extends
across mobile platforms,
as well.
On Android, we provide
Google Play services.
This is a background service
already running on most
Android devices that lets you
easily make Google API calls.
This means that to invoke the
Sign-In flow, you call connect
on the PlusClient library, and
the Sign-In flow initiates.
Similarly, we have a
native SDK for iOS.
To start the Sign-In flow, you
would need to configure the
GPPSignIn shared singleton
instance.
Then you can go ahead and make
authenticated calls, once the
user authorizes your app.
So now that we have an
authenticated user, Jonathan
will tell you more about how you
can personalize your site
to give the user a
good experience.
JONATHAN BERI: Thank
you, Ridhima.
So the user's connected with
your service and has allowed
to access their Google
account.
So at this point, you want to
start personalizing that
experience, integrating their
Google information to make
their login view personal
to them.
You can start integrating their
profile to make it an
engaging new user experience.
You can streamline registration,
or you can even
forego registration all together
and start pulling
their profile and making
them that new user.
You can also start using their
Circles, the people in their
Circles, and suggest content
and connections,
based on that data.
So let's take a look
at two examples.
So this is Flixster.com,
who has already
integrated Google+ Sign-In.
And this is one of
my real accounts.
You can see they've pulled in
my profile information, so I
know which account
I'm logged into.
They have my first and
last name that
they've pulled in directly--
I've never typed that in.
And behind the scenes, they are
doing a few other things
which are not clear here.
But they have my Google email.
So they're actually sending me
email notifications when
videos and films that I'm
tracking are now in theaters
or available to purchase.
On the side, they actually pull
in my Google Circles.
These are friends of mine who
are using Google+ Sign-In and
are using Flixster.
So this way, I can start
tracking their activity and
see what they're doing
right on Flixster.
And this is a pretty powerful
integration, integrating
Circles to help me discover
my friends.
But using that same data, you
could have a more meaningful
experience.
Let's take a look at Banjo.
Banjo is another integration
partner of Google+ Sign-In.
And they do something
very powerful here.
What they do is they take a
bunch of different social
networks, and they do joins
across those networks.
And they help me discover people
I might be interested
in, based off of my social
connections.
So by taking the people in my
circle, these connections that
I talked about earlier, you can
make for a more meaningful
experience.
This is an engagement tool.
You can use social connections
to help users discover new
content, whether that be new
people to follow or maybe a
new interesting video that
their friends are
watching right now.
Again, this is helping those
users stay longer and interact
more deeply.
Now Ridhima, to see some code.
RIDHIMA KEDIA: Thank
you, Jonathan.
So now that we have an
authenticated user, we can
start making authenticated API
requests to fetch their social
data, like their profile
data or their friends.
We have client libraries in all
major languages and native
SDKs for mobile.
Once again, let's look at
web for an example.
So for our client libraries,
we have built a common
infrastructure that we call
the Discovery Service.
Using metadata, we dynamically
build native
methods for an API.
This means that you only have to
use a single client library
for any Google API call.
So if you're making any Google
API calls in your application,
you would already be familiar
with these client libraries.
Loading the plusone.js
code snippet defines
the gapi local object.
We can use this now to load
different client modules.
In order to make social API
calls, we would load the plus
v1 module here.
If we had wanted to make
calender API calls, we would
have loaded the calendar
v3 module here.
Loading the plus v1
module defines the
gapi client plus object.
Now if you want to fetch the
user's profile data, you would
call people.get on
this object.
You would need to specify the
user ID which you want to
fetch data for.
If you want to fetch data for
the currently logged in Google
user, we provide you
a shortcut-- me.
Similarly, if you had wanted to
fetch the user's friends,
we would call people.list on
the same object, again
specifying the same user ID
parameter for which you again
have the shortcut, me.
In addition, you would need to
specify the collection visible
parameter to fetch those friends
that are visible to
your app, as selected
by the user.
Now that we have defined the
function, we can execute it,
providing a JavaScript function
that will receive
this profile data and actually
personalize your app.
Now that we understand how
personalization works,
Jonathan will tell you how
Google+ platform provides
interactive sharing.
JONATHAN BERI: Thank
you, Ridhima.
So if your application
has content, users
want to share that.
And as a developer or content
creator, you want them to be
sharing that content, so
you get more users.
But we've noticed a problem
with social sharing today.
Let's say you convince somebody
that this is worth
sharing, and they'll share
it out to their networks.
Their friends may see that on
their already busy stream.
If something really catches
their eye, they may click on
that link and go to your site.
If it's a video, they might
watch it, they might drop out,
and you'll have a
balanced rate.
But you really are not getting
the kind of engagement that
you're really looking for.
So we set out to do a new
type of sharing--
a form of targeted sharing that
enables users to reach
out to their friends on Google
and then bring them to your
app with the mindset to already
start engaging.
And we call this interactive
posts.
Let's walk through an
interactive post.
So the first thing you'll
notice, this looks like a
social share.
It has a Share button.
There's a link associated with
it, and it's very similar to
the other types of shares
we do on Google today.
But the most obvious difference
is a big button--
a call to action button.
This is a button that when
it shows up in the
stream will stand out.
And it's clickable.
So if a user sees that and is
interested in the description
and the copy, they will click
on that button, and it will
take them somewhere.
Where you take them is a deep
link that you provide.
Whether they're on mobile or
web, we will route them to the
context that you specify.
And that should be the context
that I originally shared out
the interactive post.
That deep link will also take
them directly to your app.
And if you don't have the
app, we'll help that
user get your app.
So interactive post is not only
a great way to increase
engagement to a targeted sharer,
but it's also a way to
capture new users.
So a few more things about
the interactive post.
As a developer, you can
pre-fill the text.
So you can set up the context
over the share.
And if a user likes what
they see, they can go
ahead and share it.
Or they can edit it.
What's really important about
interactive post, besides
being targeted and interactive,
is that it is
user-generated.
So when one of your friends
receives an interactive post
notification, they know it
actually came from you.
So that helps with conversion
and making this share a more
meaningful share for both the
sender and the recipient.
The last thing I want
to highlight is the
names at the top.
So when you share, you have
a target, you set the
recipients.
But as a developer,
you can pre-fill
the recipient targets.
And this includes email.
So if you already have users in
your system with email from
a username password or through
another social network, you
can target and pre-fill across
networks via email.
Extremely powerful, especially
for marketing, especially for
growing your cross-network
user base.
So let's walk through
a scenario of
an interactive post.
And we're going to use OpenTable
as an example.
And OpenTable has integrated
Google+ Sign-In.
And we'll do just a little
bit of role play here.
So fast forward three days,
we're all done with I/O, and
the team wants to go out for a
delicious dinner to celebrate
a successful event.
There's a fantastic ceviche
place just down on the
Embarcadero.
But I want to make sure
that the restaurant
has options for everybody.
So I start reviewing the menu.
It looks good.
There's vegetarian options, of
course, ceviche, and a little
Pisco Sour for those of us
who need to relax a bit.
And I want to share this out
with the rest of the team, so
they can decide if they
want to join.
So OpenTable has integrated an
interactive post button.
This is a customizable button
that looks right in their UI.
When I click that button, I get
that familiar dialogue we
just saw a moment ago.
They have that view menu that
when my friends see it and my
colleagues see it, they'll know
that there's a menu on
the other side.
So I go ahead and share
it with Ridhima.
Ridhima has her Android phone in
her pocket, and she gets a
little buzz.
That buzz has a notification
that somebody has directly
shared something with her, which
is an interactive post.
It's a notification that
actually stands out above
others, so that she knows that
there's something waiting for
her, like a direct message.
She clicks on that notification,
and she's taken
to the stream where she can
see that full share with
pre-filled text that OpenTable
provided, the image, and that
call to action button.
When she clicks on that call
to action button, there's a
deep link behind it.
And we take her directly to
the context that OpenTable
wanted her to, which
is the menu that I
was originally sharing.
So now she's in OpenTable,
engaging directly, reviewing
the menu, and can confirm
that reservation at a
later point in time.
We have over 100 different
labels
for our call to actions.
These are configurable labels.
And we're seeing developers
adding multiple types.
Because this goes beyond a
standard social share.
There's an action associated
with it.
So let's say you're a publisher
site, and you have
video content.
You might want to have a Watch
button, where users click that
button, and they're taken
to a video that starts
automatically.
Sorry, that was a Podcast one.
We also have Listen and Watch.
Let's say you're an educational
site, and you want
to take users straight to the
content to avoid registration.
You might have a Learn button.
And if you have your own
commenting system, you would
have a Comment and Reply.
Of course, there's e-commerce
solutions, where you want to
have a user, see that
Buy button, see
something they like.
And when they click it, they're
taken directly to the
checkout page with that
item pre-filled.
We're also seeing partners
combining it in multiple
different ways and intelligent
ways to make it
part of your app--
not just a little share
icon off the center.
Because they want to drive
users to share more
targetedly.
And just like the rest
of the platform, it's
very easy to integrate.
So back to Ridhima to
show us that code.
RIDHIMA KEDIA: Thank
you, Jonathan.
For interactive posts, we've
built on existing Google
sharing plug-ins and APIs.
And all of our client libraries
and mobile SDKs
package it up for easy
integration.
We have built in deep links.
This means that no matter which
device a user views an
interactive post in, on clicking
it, they will be
taken to the right context
within your application.
Once again, let's take the
web as an example.
Just like the Sign-In flow,
the interactive post flow
starts with a rendered
button that you can
configure through markup.
Now we've omitted some of the
fields here, but if you look
at the important bits, the call
to action label can be
specified by an enum, and the
compete list is documented in
a developer site.
We just saw a preview off all
the different actions
that you can take.
It could be Buy, Comment,
View, Watch,
Listen, you name it.
The call to action URL is the
URL which the users will be
taken to if they click on
the interactive post on
plus.gooogle.com.
The deep link ID takes the user
directly to the right
context within your application,
if they click on
the post in one of the mobile
versions of Google+.
You can pre-define a pre-filled
text that will be
populated in the share, which
of course, can be
edited by the user.
You can pre-define a list of
recipients, up to 10 users.
It can be specified in the form
of Google user IDs or any
email addresses.
Do you notice some familiar
fields here like client ID,
scope, request visible
actions?
These are all similar
to the Sign-In flow.
That is because the interactive
post also takes
the user through the Sign-In
flow if they have not
already signed in.
This is especially useful for
the use case in which you want
the user to sign in only when
they want to share.
So this is yet another
way we help you get
more signed in users.
For comparison, here is a
snippet of the interactive
post integration on iOS.
As you can see, the syntax may
be different, but the code
pieces are exactly the same.
So this is amazing
for developers.
Since if you understand how
interactive posts work on one
platform, you can easily
integrate it
into any other platform.
Now that we've talked about
sharing, Jonathan will tell
you how you can write back
different App Activities that
the user takes within your
site, back to Google.
JONATHAN BERI: Thank you.
So you have a logged in
user, and they're
taking all these actions.
They might be uploading
content, they might be
reading, they might be
creating new things.
And all these actions are
happening within your
application, but other users
don't know about this.
They're not discoverable.
So with Google+ Sign-In, we
enabled something we call App
Activities.
It's a way for you, as a
developer, to write to Google,
so that we can surface those
activities to other users,
across Google, at
the right time.
We actually demoed this
integration just the other
week at TechCrunch Disrupt.
So here's how one such
integration would look like.
So let's say a user's searching
for Fandango--
Fandango has integrated
Google+ Sign-In.
All those activities that users
are taking with their
app, they're sending
to Google.
And Google is aggregating those
activities, anonymizing
them, to show other users what
is trending on Fandango.
This way, other Fandango users
might discover new and
interesting content based off
of Google users, as a whole,
or even help Fandango
get new users by
discovering their brand.
These are clickable links in the
knowledge cart that, like
we saw before, are a deep link,
which would take the
user directly to Fandango, to
the right context, to the
video, where they can start
seeing the trailer or even
purchasing tickets.
This is the direction we want
to go with this product.
We want to help you to surface
your apps in more meaningful
ways across Google by making
those activities users are
taking in a social context
useful for others.
And this is the very first place
that we're integrating
App Activities.
And just like the rest
of the APIs, it's
very easy to integrate.
RIDHIMA KEDIA: Thank
you, Jonathan.
So now that you have a signed
in user, you can write back
different App Activities that
the user takes within your
site back to Google.
And as Jonathan just showed,
we can surface them in
interesting and relevant
contexts.
We have already seen that we
have client libraries in most
popular languages and native
SDKs for mobile.
All we do now is use one of
those client libraries and
call an API to write these
moments back to Google.
So here's a sample of our
Python client library.
To write an activity back, you
would need to specify the
activity type.
Again, for example, if you
wanted to write back user
purchase events, you would
specify the Buy
activity type here.
This should be an activity type
that you have already
configured in your
Sign-In markup.
And the user would have
explicitly granted access to
this type when they see
the consent dialogue.
In addition, you would specify
a target URL, which should
contain the schema dot markup
for the activity type you have
just specified.
Now that we understand how the
different pieces of the
Sign-In flow come together,
Jonathan will summarize all
that we have learned today.
JONATHAN BERI: Great.
So let's do a little
bit of review.
We saw the Google+
Sign-In button--
the easiest way for you to
acquire new users by enabling
them to connect their Google
account with your app.
We saw how you can take that
user and create a personalized
experience with their Google
profile and their
connections on Google.
We talked about how you can
increase engagement by using
interactive posts to get users
to bring their friends back
into your app and interacting
immediately.
And the last bit we just
talked about, our App
Activities that we can use to
surface relevant information
across Google.
Now today, I went through
everything very quickly and
very briefly.
There's a ton of detail to
make this an awesome
integration, depending on your
platform and your type of
integration.
Throughout the rest of Google
I/O, we have sessions on every
feature, in great detail, from
beginning with Android to best
practices across the web
and boot camps--
sorry--
code labs that get you started
and get you finished.
So I suggest if you're
interested in any of these
topics that you attend
one of these.
And if you're in the live
stream, a lot of them will be
available to watch, as well.
A quick credit to the images I
used earlier, and I want to
thank you for getting interested
in Google+ Sign-In.
Three important links before
we take questions--
one is our developer site, which
you've seen already.
It's developers.google.com/+.
That's the overall
developer site.
We use our Google+ page and
our Google+ community to
engage with conversation and
answer questions about
different topics, so I suggest
you add the Google+ Developers
page to your Circles.
And the last is our Stack
Overflow page.
This is where we do a
lot of our support.
So if you have technical
questions that you can't
figure out through the
documentation, this is a great
place to go.
Again, my name is Jonathan Beri,
joined by Ridhima Kedia.
And we thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
JONATHAN BERI: Awesome.
So we have plenty of
time for questions.
So for those who are here,
come up to the mic.
And we're going to try to figure
out how I can do the
online thing in a second.
And let's start, left first.
AUDIENCE: One puzzlement that
I've had is the sign
out from the app.
I don't know whether it's
best practice--
because you can have them sign
out completely out of Google
or just sign out of your app.
And how do you serve that
to the customer, so they
understand if they're going to
sign out of their Google
account or just out
of the account?
And what's your recommended
best practice for that?
JONATHAN BERI: So that's
a great question.
It's about sign out.
We've seen a few different
implementations of sign out.
A lot of you developers just
want to keep it logged in.
As long as they're logged into
Google, they want to keep them
logged into your service.
But some users expect
sign out.
We made it really easy
to disconnect.
So when they want to
disassociate their Google
account with your service,
we have an API
that makes that easy.
And we've seen already
developers implement their own
form of sign out.
It really depends
on their logic--
how they treat a user, what the
need is to be signed in.
Is it in the browser?
Is it in the server?
And we actually have a session
on best practices where we
talk about it, as well as
authorization, where we talk a
little bit more about
sign out.
But it entirely depends
on your integration.
AUDIENCE: Well, I guess, let's
say a person's traveling--
they're at a hotel.
Maybe they just signed out of
your app, but they're still
logged into their Gmail.
Someone could go access
their mail.
Or they're at home, and they're
doing their daily
activities, and they sign out.
You just signed them out of
their Google account, so how
do you deal with that?
It seems like it's confusing
to the customer.
JONATHAN BERI: Typically,
especially the services that
do really care about sign out,
is they track it themselves.
So they'll use their own cache,
whether that be a
cookie or local storage, to
say this user signed out.
Or if that user is in the
server, then they're going to
basically disassociate that
server with that currently
logged in session.
So we can talk about that more
after, depending on how your
app is built.
AUDIENCE: All right,
thank you.
JONATHAN BERI: Sure thing.
Let's go--
[INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about Android, but I guess it
applies to any application.
Let's say I want to use other
Google APIs like Tasks or
Google URL Shortening
and stuff like that.
Can I use this, and then add
another scope, and then ask
only one set of permissions
to the user?
Or it's something different and
then I need to ask user
multiple things, like give you
access to your Google+
profile, let me put Tasks
or stuff like that?
JONATHAN BERI: Yeah,
great question.
The question is, can I use
multiple scopes at one time?
AUDIENCE: Yep.
JONATHAN BERI: And the answer
is absolutely, yes.
We showed some snippet
of code.
Basically, when you set up the
Sign-In button, if it's
Android, if it's iOS, web, you
pass in multiple scopes.
So we show the user an
expandable dialogue with each
line representing a scope.
And also for the mobile
context, especially on
Android, they also approve the
hardware permissions as well,
in that same single dialogue.
AUDIENCE: So is there any reason
to use the other Google
account authentication process
from the services?
It seems like it's better
to use Google+, right?
JONATHAN BERI: So you mean the
local account manager?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JONATHAN BERI: That's the
current way, right?
AUDIENCE: Mm-hmm.
JONATHAN BERI: And now the
Google+ way gets you a lot
more user information--
so more about their profile,
more about their connections.
So you can make a lot more
meaningful social app, versus
just knowing their email.
So with Google+ Sign-In, we
provide you access to all
those additional pieces of
information about the user.
AUDIENCE: OK.
JONATHAN BERI: So we would
recommend you use Google+
Sign-In for that.
AUDIENCE: Cool, thank you.
JONATHAN BERI: This one.
AUDIENCE: Great presentation,
really
exciting what you're doing.
JONATHAN BERI: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: My question is
basically the same as what he
had, just want to make sure
to clarify though.
So my question is, if I start
with a certain set of scopes,
and then I want to escalate the
user later, like I want to
start with a certain set of
scopes that are very limited,
and I escalate, do I
have then two OAuth
tokens that I'm managing?
Or is it a single OAuth token?
Because I could see that if I'm
having to manage multiple
tokens on my app side--
so is it a single OAuth
token that will be
resolved at the end?
Or is it multiple, and
do I have to do work?
Can you just talk a little
bit about that?
RIDHIMA KEDIA: So you will
get two OAuth tokens.
We'd recommend you keep the
later one, because it will
have the greater set
of permissions, and
revoke the older one.
And then go ahead and
use the later one.
AUDIENCE: OK.
JONATHAN BERI: And we're also
looking at how to make that a
better experience.
RIDHIMA KEDIA: Yeah.
JONATHAN BERI: So keeping
following our blog and our
Google+ page to learn more
about how we're improving
authorization and APIs.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I built
an app for GitHub.
And I have like 400 OAuth tokens
in there, and I didn't
realize I was doing that.
So that's something that--
yeah, great.
Thanks.
JONATHAN BERI: Cool.
I like your app.
This way.
AUDIENCE: So what about a
progressive enhancement.
I want to allow people to log
in with any OAuth provider
but, if they have a G+ account,
get the additional
capabilities.
How would that work?
JONATHAN BERI: So when you mean
any OAuth provider, do
you mean outside of Google?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
JONATHAN BERI: So we've seen
a few solutions in the
marketplace.
Typically, it depends on which
type of networks you're trying
to target--
if it's a business oriented
product, if it's a consumer
oriented product, if you have
your own OAuth provider.
But we think options is a good
thing, but not too many.
Because that creates the
paralysis of choice.
So we're seeing usually maybe
two providers in a single
dialogue, depending
on which are your
two greatest networks.
And then you just can provide
them as options.
And then on your back end,
you basically have
a table of a user.
And it's this social login
versus Google social login,
maybe username and password.
And you can just keep it
as a unified record.
AUDIENCE: So I would have to
have a Sign-In with G+ and a
Sign-In with Gmail if they just
had a Google account.
JONATHAN BERI: Oh, I see.
So one thing that I hope I can
convey is Google+ Sign-In is
the way we want developers to
allow users to connect their
Google account with
your service.
So think of Google as
a Google Sign-In.
It's a Google+ Sign-In,
but it's Sign-In
with your Google account.
So you should use Google+
Sign-In as your Google way to
authenticate.
If you want to, let's say,
support GitHub, then you could
provide that as a secondary
Sign-In option, and combine
the user accounts that way.
Cool?
Good question.
AUDIENCE: Hello, I think you
might have mentioned this, but
a really simple question.
When you mentioned that for deep
links, if you don't have
the app, does Google Play do
anything to carry that
referring source through the
installation process?
RIDHIMA KEDIA: Yes.
JONATHAN BERI: Absolutely.
So on Android, if I'm on the
Android app, the new beautiful
Android app, I click
that deep link.
If the user doesn't have your
app installed, we'll take them
to the Play Store, we'll prompt
them to install it.
When they're done, they'll get
a notification saying, do you
want to continue to
that deep link?
So they'll actually go exactly
to the right deep link, and
we'll pass the deep
link to your app.
Even on iOS, we help the user
go to the app store.
And we help them get to the
final deep link, as well.
AUDIENCE: OK, how does
it work on iOS?
Did you--
JONATHAN BERI: We can talk
more about the specifics.
But essentially, we take them
to the app store, and we use
the [? pay span ?]
to get them as a saved link.
And they can go all
the way through.
So mostly, they get there.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
JONATHAN BERI: Cool.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering,
how flexible are
the actions or contexts?
I know there's probably
a standard set.
But is there a way to
extend that set?
JONATHAN BERI: So start from
the beginning again.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: I guess, how flexible
are the actions or
the deep links, the contexts?
JONATHAN BERI: OK, so the
interactive posts, the call to
action labels.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JONATHAN BERI: It
is a thick set.
We have over 100 of what we've
heard are the most common.
And we're always up to add some
more ones that you think
would help a larger
population.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
JONATHAN BERI: Cool.
AUDIENCE: Basically, it's very
exciting to see the Sign-In
process to give access
to developers
for actual user data.
When would you think that we'd
be able to get access for
friend data, so we could build
smarter algorithms for finding
out friend affinity or content
analysis and things like that
off of say, the pages
that your friends
actually like on Google+.
JONATHAN BERI: So in the
beginning, I talked about
security and privacy.
AUDIENCE: Mm-hmm.
JONATHAN BERI: And the model
we're building right now is
the user has to authenticate.
And we're being very
conservative on what
user data you get.
So when a user does sign in,
we allow them to give you
access to their flat Circles.
And that includes the public
Google ID, first name, last
name, and profile picture.
I don't know if we're ever going
to go to that direction,
but we'd love to hear your use
cases and see how we can make
them happen.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
JONATHAN BERI: Cool, and I think
we're done for time.
I'll be around here
after the talk.
And of course, we have our
sandbox, where you can ask me
and the rest of the team
more questions.
Thank you, everybody.
RIDHIMA KEDIA: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]